fortran a compiled imperative
programming language famous as the first
ever high-level language designed for
humans it was developed in the 1950s at
ibm by john bakkus a guy who was too
lazy to write assembly for the ibm 704
mainframe computer the haters said it
would never be as performant as
hand-coded programs but by 1957 formula
translator became the first computer
language standard at the time computers
were extremely rare but fortran was a
huge technical breakthrough because for
the first time ever people outside the
computer science realm could actually
use a computer most importantly the
language implemented the first
optimizing compiler which was able to
produce machine code just as fast as
anything coded by hand the language has
evolved into many different versions
over the years and is still in use today
primarily for heavy duty number
crunching and scientific computing when
your grandma wrote fortran back in the
70s she didn't have access to fancy
tools like editors and terminals and
instead wrote her code on a punch card
each card represents one line of code
and is kept neatly in a stack where it
can then be fed into a card reader to be
compiled the modern developer can get
started by installing the fortran
compiler then create a file ending in f
or f95 to specify a certain version like
fortran 95 use the program keyword to
give your app a name in older versions
keywords used all caps because the shift
key didn't exist on punch card machines
until the 1970s declare variables by
starting with a type followed by a name
and optionally a default value any
variable names that start with ijklmn
will automatically be considered
integers to disable this ancient feature
use the implicit nun directive at the
top use the character type to create a
string by declaring it with a fixed
maximum length now print that value to
the standard output using the executable
statement of print star in addition the
dimension keyword can be used to create
an array of numbers and multiple
dimensions will create a matrix just be
careful not to allocate too much memory
because your apple ii only has four
kilobytes of ram early versions of the
language didn't perform fine-grained
memory management but modern versions
support pointers that can manually
allocate and de-allocate memory but the
real killer feature of fortran when it
came out in the 50s is the ability to
perform loops perform loose perform
loose the do and do while loops made it
relatively easy for anybody to tell a
computer how to do something multiple
times on top of that fortran also made
code reusable with procedures a function
procedure takes immutable arguments
performs some kind of calculation then
returns a value it can be called with
its name elsewhere in the code a
subroutine is another type of procedure
which can take mutable arguments but
does not provide a return value now use
your favorite implementation of the
compiler to convert your code into an
executable binary this has been fortran
and 100 seconds let me know if you want
to see a full tutorial in the comments
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one